you okay son
thank you apologies for absence
we have none
no it's subs all right we're sorry
apologies have been received from
councillor christie mason
councillor michael hoyer will substitute
for her
non-members attending i have councillor
councillors james gooding cheryl rowe
mike septo
ian wald simon woodson and james newport
how i missed anyone
no oh sorry i'm sorry uh eileen gudson
sorry just
she's just coming thank you
members do we agree the minutes of the
meeting held on the 2nd of april
thank you do we receive declarations of
interest
councilman steptoe
can you keep it there with councillor
williams as well please
[Music]
one of them
sorry item 6 speak upon also as county
councillor for the same area
and also that i the agent for the
development is and the owner is known to
me
thank you
council williams thank you chairman um
i'm not particularly interested in the
fact that i am an award
counsellor and also the chairman of the
parish council
and that is parish
also that i am known to the applicant
thank you very much uh
councillor goodin behind you
board counsellor for
and also a member of rochester parish
council thank you
thank you council award
on item six i am known by the owner of
the site
is that it yeah thank you what
interests have you got council award
please none whatsoever
no procurement is a personal interest
interest at all
just a personal interest just i just he
knows me
thank you very much councillor woodson
thank you madam chairman a non-pecuniary
interest
of knowing the applicant on item six
terry richard
thank you very much councillor this is
ryan
thank you chairman same as councillor
thank you
have we got any more
more council fighters
you don't have to declare it but it's in
the interest of transparency sometimes
if you would like to declare as a ward
councillor for item
it's a matter for you if you'd like to
declare
thank you
have you all got you the addendums for
items six and seven and have you all
read them please
all good no one said anything
right okay item six
this is the application twenty stroke
zero zero zero
nine one three stroke out um cherry
aldrid brickworks
can i ask the officers yes
can i just everyone can hear me i hope
and start with plan one so
sorry this application into a proposed
retirement village
and mixed use development it is an
outline application with all matters
reserved except for access
as you can see so we've got the red line
here showing the site boundary
here it's cherry ultra brickworks a 4.19
hectare former brickwork site
yes i'll zoom right in and i'll outline
it with my
pointer for you i'm very sorry there you
go
is that okay
so we have watchful to the north east
over here and this is hall road located
here as well
and then the site is to the east of
cherry orchard lane so coming down here
and on the opposite side of the road is
cherry orchard jubilee country park
too so as you can see here so the site
is actually where you can see
most of the earth works occurring just
to give you a bit of an idea of the site
area
and it's an aerial perspective the site
location that we're looking at now so
immediately to the south of the
application site
is a business park under construction
and partly occupied that was granted
planning permission in 2016.
we also have a row of residential
dwellings here a border in the site and
a children's nursery on the site that
was granted commission in 2018.
to the north we have nobles greenbrook
and beyond that ashland football pitches
so there were two key elements to the
scheme a retirement village and mixed
use development
the retirement village would include 63
retirement apartments
30 assisted living apartments 30 shelter
departments
a 93 bed care home and six dwellings the
mix use development would include a
convenience store
medical facilities pharmacy hydrotherapy
pool coffee shop
gymnasium office space and community
space
members will have seen a very similar
application before at this site
this application was refused by members
and is currently at appeal pending a
hearing date
officers have considered the changes
made between the refused scheme and that
currently submitted
but the remain concerns which are
referred to within the report and have
led to a recommendation for refusal by
officers
it should also be noted that planning
mission has been approved at this site
for a proposed business park in 2018.
so the key changes between the refused
application and that currently under
consideration are as follows
we looking at a retirement accommodation
that no longer specified as over 55s
there are 63 retirement apartments of
varying sizes that are now proposed
compared with 32
over 55 apartments proposed previously
the current application seeks six market
dwellings compared with 22 over 55
houses and nine over 55 bungalows
proposed previously
the 30 shelter departments are now
proposed compared with 35
and there's been an increase in
commercial community space increased
parking provision
the 30 assisted living apartments and 93
unit care home remain
unchanged so the key material planning
considerations are
the principle of the development
commercial demand existing provision of
employment development
housing need sustainability quantum type
and proportion of residential use
affordable housing access flood risk and
drainage
sustainable transport parking provision
archaeology
ecological impact trees environmental
impact
environmental sustainability public open
space and indicative design and layout
so let's look at principles of
development first
so this plan shows the proposals map for
the joint area action plan
and our site area is the one labeled
number one here just showing here
so policy nel3 of the allocations plan
identifies the area north of london
south and airport has been a key driver
for the sub-regional economy
policy e3 of the [ __ ] allocates land
incorporating the application site and
surrounding areas to the south and east
for new employment use as part of
proposed new business park
split into three areas known as one two
and three so they're here so
we've got two and three which is the
areas to the south here and then this is
the area one so our
application site takes up a large
portion of area one
areas two and three already benefit from
planning permission for business use and
work has commenced
the current proposal relates to area one
the airport business park is part of the
joint area action plan that looks ahead
to 2031
and accounts for increased passenger
movements at london south and airport
that are anticipated
in the coming years this allocation is
an important opportunity to provide more
employment
opportunities locally including higher
skilled jobs and he's both watchful and
south end
joint strategy for providing these
employment opportunities in the longer
term
i'll just point out those areas again
now i wasn't aware that we had a bit of
sun perhaps on the screen so
area one here and current application
and then two and three
and the areas again for business part
usage at the south there
so this shows um policy e3 which is one
of the main policies that we're
considering as part of this application
so the current proposal whilst providing
an element of commercial use such uses
to supplement the residential and is not
to the quantum and types sought within
the jack
which as can be seen here is b1 and
educational usage so here we've got area
one
and it refers to b1 education in this
section here
the council's economic development team
explained clearly in their consultation
response the reasons why it is important
to retain this unique
strategic site as a business park at
paragraph 4.25
to 4.51 of the officer report the
proposal goes against policies within
the [ __ ]
allocations plan and call strategy which
seek to retake it retain this site
for employment land and is recommended
for refusal for this reason
moving on to commercial demand so
commercial demand reps is an important
consideration here the applicant has
provided two assessments of local need
for office space from local property
agents arguing there is a current lack
of demand
the pandemic has had a significant
short-term impact on demand for office
space
and is broadly accepted that airport and
airline industry growth has been paused
there is however no evidence provided
that office demand will not increase by
2031.
the [ __ ] is up to date and still within
the first half of its lifespan are only
seven years old
with an approximate 10 years still until
2031.
it is considered that the current
reduction in office space demand and the
working pattern changes accelerated by
kovic 19
are material considerations but reflect
poorly short-term
economic and social changes with little
evidence of a long-term or permanent
shift in demand for commercial
development in the watchford area
to approve an application which would
result in the loss of dedicated
employment land within an area
considered regionally economically
important
at a relatively early stage in the
planned process has the potential to
result in pressure to seek alternative
employment land
in less suitable locations within the
district in the future
so looking at existing provision of
provision of employment development
another material consideration is the
current level of commercial industrial
provision in those areas two and three
i'll just go back to those areas
so in these areas here two and three of
the jab allocation
some commercial floor space would be
provided within the proposed development
primarily serving the main use as a
retirement village
these uses would not form part of a
business park but would fall under the
broadly commercial new use class e
it is acknowledged that the additional
provisional floor space in areas two and
three mean that an additional 6098 metre
squared of employment provision
in area one would meet the minimum floor
space allocation set out in policy e3
the aim of the jack is for high quality
development for employment land however
and the above considerations do not tilt
the balance in favor of the proposal
sufficiently to outweigh the conflict
with the development plan and
medium-term growth
strategy within the gap
following publication of the 2020
housing delivery test results in which
the council scored 95 percent
the council no longer needs to apply to
20 buffer to its five-year housing land
supplier calculations so this is now
looking at housing need
in light of the above the council
considers it can now demonstrate around
a 6.3 year housing land supply
therefore lack of five-year housing
supply is not considered an argument
here
this proposal seeks to case to a more
specific demographic though in providing
retirement village to include sheltered
housing assisted living
retirement homes and a care home the
current level of demand for specialist
housing for older people locally has
been identified as low
according to the council's strategic
housing team taking into consideration
developments such as the roachway sites
of 60 assisting living units and five
sheltered accommodation units that exist
in watford already
there is also an application under
consideration by barchester nursing home
for a 60 bed
care home on london road raleigh demand
in the region is likely to increase
steadily over the next two decades
however
the potential future need for the
proposed development must be weighed
against the suitability of the pose
location
and it is not considered that potential
future demand outweighs the objections
to the site location
looking at sustainability the site is
not currently serviced by public
transport and is not within convenient
walking distance to watchful
centre and the services and facilities
within the town
including supermarkets and the train
station this would result in a somewhat
self-contained residential facility
isolated from the wider residential
parts of rochefort
the site would also be adjacent to
employment uses including b2 general
industrial uses
which are those considered not suitable
to be located alongside residential use
and the retirement village would gain
access through this neighbouring
business park
it is considered the proposal would not
constitute sustainable development
the proposal would fail to meet the
social tests within the mppf
sustainability objectives by virtue of
the isolated nature of the development
the lack of existing public transport
infrastructure and the proximity to an
incompatible adjoining land use which
would share access to the main road
the provision of medical care private
transport options and other essential
facilities
internally within the retirement village
would not offset the lack of overall
sustainability for the type of use
imposed
and this represents an officer reason
for refusal here
looking at the quantum type and
proportion of residential use policy h5
of the core strategy requires that new
developments contain a mix of dwelling
types to ensure located for all people
within the community
whatever their housing needs it is
considered that the provision of housing
suitable for older people would outweigh
the lack of a greater housing mix
proposed here
this does not represent an office of
reason for refusal
looking at affordable housing policy h4
of the course strategy does not refer
specifically to affordable housing being
required
in relation to dwellings proposed within
the c3 use class but rather is more
generally termed
to apply to proposals for dwellings
following recent high court decisions
it has concluded that all of the
proposed residential development
excluding the care home
could have the potential to be properly
regarded as creating dwellings to which
an affordable housing requirement would
apply
this requirement would be approximately
45 units
the council strategic housing team has
identified that there is a need for
affordable housing
which is not sheltered so class c3
rather than class c2
as the quantum of affordable housing
would be largely c2 housing
this would not best meet the affordable
housing need in rochford and this
represents a further officer reason for
refusal here
looking at access
access is for consideration at the
outline stage the main access point will
be from the northern junction of the
roundabout
between area one and areas two and three
of the wider [ __ ] zone
so the areas we're talking about is here
so this is the the main roundabout
um off the chair which away and then we
come along here and this is a newer
roundabout within the
um business parking state of areas two
and three and then you'll be accessing
the site up along here to the north
the proposal includes an access point to
the southern boundary which would
utilize the new roundabout access of
cherry which way
required by the high rail authority in
relation to the earlier commercial
scheme
this mirrors the access proposals for
the previously refuse scheme which were
considered acceptable
the other areas locate access located in
the south western corner
so here would be for emergencies only
in relation to internal access footpaths
and rows the indicative plans
demonstrate that suitable space could be
provided for safe and accessible access
routes
further details will be secured at the
reserve matter stage the outline access
arrangements are considered acceptable
looking at flood risk and drainage
the majority of the proposed development
will be accommodated within flood zone
one
however a band extending across the
central part of the site east west falls
within flood zone two
with a small proportion of the northwest
hall of the site within flood zone three
as located here
we also have a smaller section of the
site along the northern side boundary
immediately adjacent to the nobles green
brook which also just falls within flood
zone three here
the environment agency has no objection
but has confirmed the application we
need to pass a sequential test
which seeks to guide development first
to flood zone one then flood zone two
a sequential test report has been
provided with the application looking at
alternative sites
however the council's call for site list
has been updated and there are a
significant number of additional sites
that the council consider should have
been considered
within the sequential test report in
order to achieve a comprehensive
assessment that have not been included
it is not therefore possible to conclude
that the sequential test has been passed
at this stage
and this represents a further officer
reason for refusal here
with regards to drainage no objection
has been received from either anglian
water or the lead local flood authority
subject to a number of planning
conditions being required it is
considered the drainage infrastructure
could be provided on the site with
details to be provided at reserve
matters stage
looking at sustainable transport policy
t4 of the jack requires a comprehensive
network of quality bus services be
provided
serving the transport needs of the south
end watchford and wider essex catchment
area
particularly linking to the new airport
railway station and other transport
interchanges
our financial contribution would be
sought by a section 106 legal agreement
towards the provision of a bus service
serving a site and adjacent business
park if the application were to be
recommended for approval
such a contribution would also be
thought towards improvements to existing
footways and cycleways within the
proximity of the site
parking provision it is not possible to
calculate the specific parking
requirements at this stage
however the indicative site plans
provided demonstrate the sufficient
parking could likely be achieved on the
site
given its size this would be addressed
in more detail at reserve matters stage
looking at archaeology as there is a
potential for deposits of local
significance at this site
a planning condition would be advised
requiring a program of archaeological
investigation
to be secured in accordance with the
written scheme of the investigation
if the application were recommended for
approval in moving on to ecological
impact
the presence of protected species such
as badgers and nesting birds was
identified on this site
impacts from development would not cause
unacceptable harm to these protected
species
subject to mitigations which could be
secured by a planning condition
and the reserve matters application
natural england's consultation response
refers to the need for suitable
alternative green space to be lived to
be delivered on
site as well as the development secure
financial contribution towards off-site
mitigation work on a perd running basis
if the application were recommended
favorably a requirement to pay the
off-site financial contribution per
dwelling
would be requirement of a section 106.
it is acknowledged that the proposal
would not deliver suitable alternative
green space however the site is across
the road from cherrywater jubilee
country park
which will offer a very close
alternative green space and no
objections they will raise the lack of
on-site provision
moving on to trees there's limited
arbitral value
identified on the site subject to the
adequate protection measures which will
be required for any at-risk trees
adjacent to the site
planting new trees within the
development will provide a net benefit
in terms of trees on the science and
visual amenity
a tree planting plan will be required as
part of the proposed site layout which
is a reserved matter
environmental impact when air quality
assessment has been provided which
concludes that no site specific
mitigation with regards to air quality
is necessary here environmental
sustainability so policy emv8
seeks to secure at least 10 of the
energy requirements from developments
from decentralized and renewable or low
carbon sources
if the application were to be approved
such requirements could be secured by
planning
condition policy emv 7 of the jack
requires all new buildings to meet the
brain standard of excellent
unless unviable or unfeasible and for
rainwater harvesting and water recycling
systems to be used
a planning condition could be imposed to
secure this if the application were to
be approved
looking at public open space policy e3
of the jack
stipulates that all development areas
will be required to contribute towards
new public open space to the north and
east of the business park
this policy requirement was met by the
reprovision of the rugby pitches
to the north and east of the business
park allocation and is not considered to
be a need
for further contribution in relation to
this current application
finally indicative plans on design and
layout so
these have been provided such as the
elevation drawing here of a possible
medical center
and show a relatively high density
proposal which is likely to be
acceptable
scale appearance and layout however are
all matters which are reserved and are
not considered in detail at this
application stage so it's important to
understand these are definitely
indicative plans that we're looking at
here
this application is recommended for
refusal with four reasons listed as
referred to within the officer report
these can be summarized as follows one
it is not in accordance with the jack
which allocates a site for employment
use as part of a business park
two it is not sustainable development
and represents poor spatial planning
due to the isolated sighting of the
residential uses and location adjacent
to a commercial and industrial zone
three the affordable housing proposed
would not best meet the identified need
in the district due to the amount of
sheltered affordable proposed
and finally four it is not possible to
ascertain that the residential scheme
proposed
meets the sequential test for flooding
due to the inadequacies of the
sequential test provided
thank you
thank you
uh can i have the speaker mr ed durant
please
um a microphone will be given to you
thank you thank you
sorry you have five minutes okay members
tonight you've been asked to consider a
scheme that will deliver a new
residential care
village that will benefit not only your
older population
but those looking for family homes that
we will be released when existing
residents downsize
the council's latest housing market
evidence has identified a need for 50
specialist housing units for older
people
every year between 2014 and 2037.
this scheme will deliver almost three
years worth of this requirement plus
a care home this is a significant
benefit
the scheme has been developed to offer
the very best care for older people
and we are happy to consider a condition
restricting the age of residents
the site will provide a retirement
community
specifically targeted to meet the needs
of the district's aging population
providing a range of accommodation with
on-site retail
healthcare facilities set in a
landscaped grounds
with walking and cycling routes this is
all designed to promote the health and
well-being of residents
this pandemic has identified many
failings and many strengths in our
society
the greatest of which is community those
areas with strong community bonds
have thrived whereas others have been
left in isolation
this care village will ensure that these
residents never feel like that again
this is not just about providing beds in
a care home it's about providing a more
sophisticated approach to older person
accommodation
you're advised by the office of the
failings of the scheme to deliver
affordable housing
we are willing to provide this within
the scheme but our conversations with
officers
have indicated that there is no need for
affordable homes for older people
should you agree that this is the case
that we have offered a financial
contribution for affordable housing to
be provided elsewhere
but to date have not been advised of
what that figure should be
your officer report has identified the
fact that the site is allocated for
employment
whilst this is factually correct it is
also important to recognize
that this is a site that has failed to
attract employment
interests despite having the planning
permission in place in a favorable
planning policy framework
the need simply doesn't exist here and
we've included evidence in our
submission of this
it is also important to recognize that
this development will generate
jobs bringing between 572 and 685
new jobs into the area these new jobs
will be in addition to the 50 people
already employed
in cherry orchard house and the 20 staff
already employed at the nursery
who are soon to be joined by 15 more
staff the rate of employment at cherry
orchard house is higher than
that of the adjacent business park and
the proposed development will continue
this trend
it will employ carers grounds people
retail and community staff
as well as health care professionals
this will add variety to your employment
market
that is in stark contrast to the
reliance on office employment
which is vitally important as we emerge
from this pandemic
the implications for office employment
as a result the new normal
that we are discovering is yet to be
fully appreciated but one thing is
obvious is that working practices have
changed
and with it office demand will be
impacted it is important that you do not
wait for this to be demonstrated further
and instead seize this opportunity to
deliver development
that will deliver new jobs for your
community the site is well located to
ensure that it is not disrupted by
surrounding activity
it also benefits from open spaces nearby
although we dispute your office's view
on the shortcomings of the site location
we highlight you to you the supporting
facilities that are included within this
development as well as the transport
connections in the form of a minibus and
car club
that we are offering this will ensure
day-to-day needs of residents are met on
the site
as well as being available to the wider
community
members you recently approved a housing
delivery action plan that rightly
prioritized the redevelopment of
underutilized land
this is entirely appropriate and this is
one of those sites
it would be right for you to include
that in your deliberations tonight
when you do so it is important to keep
in mind that the housing requirements
that you are planning to meet are not
maximum targets but minimum
requirements whether a five-year
supplier exists or not
you're entitled to give weight to the
benefits of this housing scheme and the
specific nature
of the job provision your office have
you got one minute
okay your office has concluded that the
sequential test has not been passed even
though we have provided a full and
robust
sequential assessment reference is made
to the possibility of alternative sites
but no such sites have been suggested to
us we would be happy to reconsider this
element of the submission
if officers would clarify which
additional sites should be considered
finally members i would remind you that
the mppf allows you to take into account
material
considerations to outweigh any policy
objections your officers have set out
the policies
that escape is in conflict with and
given their view on the material
considerations
i would ask that you consider your own
view of these and in doing so the
matters that i've raised with you
tonight
two things are certain as a result
sorry your five minutes are up sorry
members are world members first please
counselor september
[Music]
thank you chairman i'd like to
pose a number of questions and
considerations i feel the committee
needs to consider
with regards to this application this
application is not dissimilar
to the previous application and if the
committees of a mined
to agree this application
i would ask what has changed in
the time that is laps between now and
then to actually make that
up opportunity
the application goes against the joint
area action plan
the question i would ask is does that
open the door and does that
what effect does that have on our joint
area action plan
the applicant suggests that he will
provide
the money or the robust service there is
no bus service currently at the moment
and to my knowledge there are no plans
for many of the bus companies to install
a bus
a bus service
if the applicant wants to put in a bus
service how can we guarantee
that that will be still there in say
five or ten years time
the state the site does not means meet
sustainable
tests for a housing estate because this
is what this basically is
so how does the committee justify going
against that advice
i'd ask the committee to take into
account where we have
agreed to housing around various
industrial areas to name for two star
lane
and roareth where housing has grown up
there has been
a steady increase in the number of
complaints
from residents that are now living
adjacent to those industrial estates
we're going to put a possibly going to
put a housing estate
which is what this is in effect right
next door to an industrial area
with all the things that go on in the
industrial area
how does the committee justify that
in the report on the refusals
the officers refer to refer to the
floodplain we have the committee has had
many applications come before it
over the years and club floodplains has
always played been an important part of
that
this does not meet the requirements for
housing in a flood plain area
there is no mention of of a
affordable housing it's a bit of a
difficult one to
justify but that goes against our own
policies
and i'd also ask the committee to
consider that some of the properties
are three-bedroom bungalows that seems a
little strange to me
that you would want a three-bedroom
bungalow in a retirement
estate
so chairman i would urge this committee
to take the officers recommendations i
do not believe that this is
the right development in this particular
place
right next door to an industrial estate
with no links and sustainability to
either rochford or to south end
and i can't see how that is going to to
to change
so i'd urge this committee to go with
the refusal
thanks chairman
members wishing to speak
counselor he can't see him
[Music]
this evening i'm here on behalf of
several residents in my ward
that possibly includes what i believe to
be a large silent majority
is those residents amongst that silent
majority have specifically asked me
about this development coming forward i
have said to them
it is within the gift of the members of
the development committee
because my residents frankly don't
understand
why the officers are recommending
refusal of this scheme
we are being told that there is
sufficient accommodation in the district
for older living
those i have spoken with and documents i
will
cite disagree those residents have
either lost their partners or our
singletons and are living at home
alone in a three or four or four bedroom
house
they no longer want to live in i'm sure
there are members here who know somebody
who fits that profile
they tell me there are no suitable
alternatives
many have suffered loneliness
accentuated over the last year by
lockdowns
what they recognize in this development
is an opportunity to be part
of a new vibrant community amongst
people like them
that will provide the activities as well
as the social and medical support they
want
and can afford as opposed to what is
currently offered
by rockford district council which is
specifically
suited for those residents who
unfortunately have no independent
financial means
which necessitates the council providing
specific
priority support we must not lose sight
of the fact
that much needed family housing can be
freed up
onto the open market as private schemes
such as this become available
our emerging local plan policies in the
housing delivery test action plan
2020 which is not cited in this current
document
with regard to bringing forward
brownfield sites as a priority
is in accord with the mppf this scheme
is situated on a brownfield
pre-use brickfield site that could be
reallocated
from office use i could detail all the
mppf policies that take precedent
over our existing policies which have
been cited this evening that supports
both this application for change
from its current status citing mppf
paras
84 117 119
120 and 121 this report also
acknowledges
the age-related growth need on page 6.12
para 3.36
for an ageing population in the district
as documented in the south essex schma
2017-2037 it should also be noted
the imr of 2019-2020 paris
3.21 two two and two three reiterates
brownfield usage as does most
importantly
our own emerging local plan statement of
intent
in the housing delivery test action plan
twenty twenty
on page twenty six neither of these
documents appear in this report
which fully support this application
being approved
which is a variance with emergence to
the emerging policies
that members of the cross party planning
policy committee
fully endorsed regarding brownfield
sites first
as a priority in summary i think all the
documents i have cited give support for
approval
for this application on several fronts
firstly
priority use of a brownfield site
secondly
with the changing commercial aspects for
the area
as recently published this application
offers employment
for up to 600 people possibly far
greater than any unnecessary office
complex
as current projections for office space
are showing
thirdly this application would
undoubtedly give credence
as well as confidence to encourage
potential users of the [ __ ] site fourthly
the [ __ ] has failed to gain any
commercial traction
or support after seven years of solid
marketing
fifthly it needs something adventurous
and exciting
to pump prime this site especially as i
remember
it was designated to be a medical
science
research and education hub delivering
high quality
sustainable jobs in conjunction with
anglia ruskin university
and not an industrial site this
application
justifiably provides a high-end
medical center which is part of the jack
vision statement
finally when circumstances change
we need to be flexible and imaginative
enough
to change with them rather than being
rigid in supporting
polities policies that economic
realities have overtaken
members one question are you satisfied
you have heard all the evidence
as the ball is firmly in your court and
the decision is yours alone
thank you chairman
thank you councilor councillor wilson
madam chairman and members thank you
very much indeed
it is somewhat unusual for me to comment
on an
application on a site which sits outside
of my ward
but i felt compelled to
say something this evening after
confessing to being a little
disappointed
with the reasons for refusal set out on
pages 6.1
and 6.2 which suggests to me
that our policies may be a bit
short-sighted
not visionary in respect of current
commercial
economic and community needs
in my opinion the proposal before you
members
is a creative and imaginative scheme
on what hitherto was a brownfield site
it will provide employment opportunities
both direct
and indirect far in excess
of what will be achieved in density
terms
of what the wider joint area action plan
will provide and i pause for a moment on
the word
words joint area action plan because
anyone that has visited that site
over a number of years will actually see
that is a huge misnomer
because it's actually the joint area in
action plan
given the time that it's had signs up
there
something of the order of 500 jobs
plus an array of indirect jobs
to service the wider needs of the
proposed community
the fact is however well-intentioned the
original
[ __ ] was the world has moved on
economic needs have changed and
those anticipated some years ago have
altered
i understand there is a demand for this
type of accommodation
so i'm at a bit of a loss to understand
when we were given the outline of the
proposal
the rationale for that those statements
that were given by officers i
furthermore i do not believe
that any applicant would be considering
an investment of this type
without having investigated the
potential market
furthermore it creates a chain of
opportunity to meet housing needs in the
district
and as for the statement about
affordable homes i believe the type of
development we're talking about here is
actually exempt
from the specific affordable
requirements
it will give a much needed boost to the
local economy
and as was mentioned just now a
world-class
medical research and training center
really putting rochford district
on the map madam chairman and members
i find this a progressive and visionary
application
accordingly it is my sincere wish that
this
receives favorable support thank you
any other non-members
members i'll open it up to yourself
counselor merrick
[Music]
oh need to mike
before we proceed to actual
questions i would be interested to hear
the
officer's response to the points we've
just been raised
no no you can't do that yet no sorry
you have to do all the speakers first
and then we go back to the offices we
can't have the officer's response
no because they haven't heard everything
yet they can't come back
yeah and so as um like i said it's only
the committee that are debating this
and we make we're the only ones that can
make the decision
but i i'm really feeling that the
officer's response
we will be able to hear the um
thank you
no no no i i was wanting to hear what
the officer said before i
considered whether i wanted to make any
further point but
in the absence of that
thank you thank you chairman um i can
recall this item coming to us
uh like last time um
but as i have a knack of doing i've
wiped
my memory and face what's on
the decision i'm coming to on the
evidence that i've heard presented
to us and it it covers a number of
points
now particularly listening to the
officer's presentation
now we are quite clearly in a confused
economic
situation at the moment to say the least
and i think it is a challenge for anyone
to demonstrate anything with any
any strength about a commercial
situation based on the
the last 18 months that we have had
i do take the point that this is a
brownfield site and it should be
considered as a priority
above some of the other
sites that are available i noted that
if we're going to put housing onto a
a site that through the [ __ ] has been
allocated for
other purposes then we perhaps should be
looking at a shortfall in our housing
need
but we've had it clearly stated by our
officers that there's a 6.3
year supply of of housing need
then we've also had mentioned that we've
got an isolated community
potentially uh popping up here um
it could be that uh such a community
is a is an innovation or a folly it's
it's it's perhaps not for us to decide
though
i am slightly confused because quite
clearly
through the rhetoric that we've heard
we're talking about
a retirement community but then we've
also clearly heard that the 55-year
age limit has been removed and i think
that's quite crucial towards the
discussion
about affordable housing so if i was to
base it
on on those four points i think at this
moment in time
i'd be inclined to support the officer's
recommendation
however however
this application provides us with a
great employment opportunity for the
district
not one that's got to wait a number of
years for the economy to
continue to develop and evolve and
recover
um this is a this is an application that
is
that is all but ready to go and
from my reading the nature of the
employment is a is a cross-section of
of job varieties and types which would
provide
need across the community i think some
of the proposed industrial use that
we've seen elsewhere on the side
is actually quite light in density
whereas this one
is potentially quite quite heavy in
employment
possibilities also is it right for us to
allow an area to sit stagnant
effectively within our district
while the
the economy recovers and business picks
itself up
i'm i'm not convinced that it is there
are a number of details
particularly around the sequential
approach
to uh flooding that do need resolving
but
as usual our officers do deal with a lot
of those matters
within reserve matters and and that
that's not uncommon
and i'm sure that um
things can be sorted out so at this
moment in time i i i'm
i'm i'm fairly evenly balanced as to
which way to go
i i understand the need
uh not sorry not the need the points
that are put in the
reasons for refusal but i'm balancing
them with the
the more immediate needs and what this
opportunity can offer to our our
district so
i i will wait to hear what a few others
mem what a few other members
have to say at this moment in time thank
you chairman
councillor
thank you chairman um
i was quite surprised to hear the um
visiting members speak so encouragingly
about this development this is
one where i've read the office report
heard the officers report i've heard the
speaker
and i just can't
disagree with the recommendations of the
officers they appear
coherent and sensible this is employment
land
um there is a part of the report i'm
just trying to find it again because i
lost my page where it it the report
suggests that the
the number of full-time equivalent jobs
that could be provided on
this application would have to be 524
full-time equivalents to make up
for the gap but all i've heard is 600
i've not heard if there's 600 full-time
equivalents
or just 600 jobs going by the nature of
the the jobs looking at this i suspect a
lot of those are part-time jobs and i
don't think it therefore meets the 524
full-time equivalents as stated in the
plan
this is employment an employment area
it's been in the [ __ ] i might have been
critical over the years of the [ __ ] but
it's been fully supported by this
council for many many years and i agree
with councillor
steptoe on that point um i i find it a
bit disingenuous that the councillors
who've been in charge of
this for a number of years i'd exclude
one of those specifically because
the council hasn't been here that long
um saying that the [ __ ] isn't fit for
purpose effectively i would disagree
with that the [ __ ] is very much
fit for purpose and it's part of our
business plan it's part part of our
our structure it's within our business
plan the chat so i would
i would at the moment i am fully
supporting the officer's recommendation
i would also just want to say that i was
quite surprised that so many
conservative members didn't actually
declare an interest i understood that
empty was spoken quite favorably about
this project and he's involved in it
through landmark capital
he is not the only one he's not that's
right he's been in the echo so i think
that needs to be corrected
he is fully understand that the echo got
that wrong i know the echo do get things
wrong
just to clarify we did go to our
monitoring officer
and to see if there was any declaration
needed there wasn't
because mr beatwell is not the agent
okay
thank you chairman um i'm going to have
to agree with councillor hoy i'm i'm not
convinced at all
with this um i'm a bit concerned when
the um
when they say this care home for the
elderly i'm thinking what do you mean by
elderly
i mean i'm 70 this year and i don't
class myself as being old
so that's a bit worrying really you talk
about
um it was brought up by another
councillor about bus service and i know
full well the bus services in our area
are absolutely diabolical
you're talking about this retirement
village
of over 200 plus
elderly i don't know um residents
um i don't again i wouldn't i
wouldn't i would be concerned with um
thinking that a resident in their own
property uh being looked at saying well
we want you to get out of this we want
your house for
a younger family and you can go and
we'll put you in this retirement village
i'm not convinced members i'm sorry this
this there's lots of things on here
that have been said about three bedroom
bungalow why does an elderly person want
a three bedroom bungalow
um it's it's come out it's it's changed
from what it was going to be for the [ __ ]
one of the officers has said there's
other areas which we could be looking at
doing um a retirement uh village
probably nearer the the areas area where
residents live now
i'm really not convinced and at the
moment i'm going to have to agree with
with the offices so
that's it thanks chairman
thank you chairman um as often been said
by the previous chairman we look at
the policies not our own individual
askings or what we might think and and
so on
it's the policies we have to deal with
and the policy is
what it is at this time through the
officers recommendations and does it
meet those policies
unfortunately it doesn't meet those
policies yes we
i agree with councillors that have
spoken before
i don't see where a person
if you like who is retired retirement if
you like
would want to go into a small place
rather than have their own front door
they still have their own front door i
know but
have their own property where they are
at the moment i certainly wouldn't give
up my property for a smaller place
that's that's
obvious and i don't see that
that there isn't so much in the way of
uh
communication in transport and in
uh shopping and so on and so on
that the shopping is quite a fair
distance away uh
from the site and unless you've got your
own transport you
obviously you know you're gonna pay a
lot more for your shopping
rather than go to the supermarket um
it's it's
things like that that we're i'm
concerned about as well
apart from i do agree with the previous
speakers
um i think the recommendation that the
officers have set forward is
a good reason for refusal um
and i'll leave it like that thank you
there are a number of things that have
been uh talked about uh with this site i
i when i first saw the application some
while ago
uh i must admit i looked at it and i
thought yes there's a good lead for this
in the area
but the problem is fundamental yes there
is a need
but it's in the wrong place i think
officers have demonstrated that quite
conclusively tonight
and one of the things that i think that
we need to pick up on
is things like some of the reasons being
why we're being told that it would be a
good idea to actually go with this where
we're talking about
that's the ward in particular suggested
that it would free up places because
there are people who are living
in three-bedroom places at the moment
who would like to move into
a retirement village where they've got
three-bedroom
accommodations that seems to kind of
mitigate or get rid of that kind of
argument quite conclusively to compare
um the possibility
of this proposal with the adjacent
business part
i consider that to be quite disingenuous
for the
the applicant's agent to be doing that
because the business park at the moment
isn't fully developed
now yes it may be slower but it is
happening we as a committee have
already uh approved factories which are
in the process of being built there
now they can't predict how many people
are going to be working
in there conclusively until they are
occupied
that is hasn't happened yet but it will
happen so
to actually compare the the situation
now um in the business park
compared to what it will be in the
future on the retirement park
i think is a bit of a red herring to say
the least
i think it's fundamental
in that we have actually as a council
agreed to the joint area action plan
now whether you agree with it or not we
have agreed with and we have agreed to
that
and the officers in my mind have
actually conclusively demonstrated
that it does not meet the
standards of the jack so there's not
much point
in us agreeing to policies if we're then
just going to brush them aside
unless we're going to bring it back to
council and change
the uh the direction of the jab
so to my mind at the moment i uh
my mind has not been altered from what
the
officers have actually come up with and
i can't see any reason at the moment
for seeing this to approval thank you
yes uh thank you chairman i have serious
concerns regarding
development it's specs of utopia specs
of gated
community it's a great it would be a
great asset to the area but um
unfortunately it's in the wrong place
and i've seen nothing this evening or
heard nothing that would make me alter
the decision made by
officers and so as from what i've seen i
could i couldn't support this
application thank you
i obviously don't know the history uh
but i believe the slow take-up
for the industrial park is not just of
the
covet era i think it's been slow over an
extended period
um to use counselor wootton's
comment it does seem a creative and
imaginative
brownfield uh proposition i do have a
reservation
about the transportation um
there's some comments being made about
people being put
into smaller places i don't think they
get put i think they choose to go there
if that's something
somewhere that's available to them it
sounds in my
in my opinion it's quite a positive
proposal
thank you members um this is in
employment land
and it needs jobs it's been there for
seven years we've nothing been built
there's
i know there's a outline plan in there
it's it's just been empty and to get
six five six hundred jobs i think would
be quite good
and as the old saying goes a bird in the
hand he's worth
two in the bush and 600 jobs now is
a good thing so as it is i'd support
this
thank you
thank you i had a report from essex
county
councillor today um because i've been
asking what the critical need was
for this site um so i eventually got it
today
um and from matthew barnett and his um
is he is committed for elderly to have
the best care
within their own home or a care home
you see i'm not reading everything
because it was about five paragraphs but
if anyone wants it i will pass it on to
them after this meeting i
didn't have time to give it out to
anyone i'm sorry
demand that there is a demand at the
moment for 221
extra care home accommodation in
addition to the existing scheme
of the one this is for rockford only
to the existing scheme at the present of
dobson's house
in raleigh which has only got 30
accommodation
so we are going to be short
with anyway for our care home or homes
for the elderly in their own homes
i would recommend this for approval
the officers officer
officers would you like to come back and
comment please
okay
yeah sorry i didn't intend to speak here
but just to clarify on that
um essex county council did come back to
our strategy strategic housing
assistant director to say that any need
in the district was currently going to
be met by the roachway development
and then additional to that we have the
balchester homes
nursing home that will be coming forward
if that is approved
so um you know obviously we haven't had
sight of that report
but just to know that we have had
information from county
to say that any need in the district at
the moment is being kind of been
met by roachway would you recommend this
to be deferred until you saw those
reports
um well as an opportunity to be deferred
if members want to be
put forward to be deferred but i just
wanted to clarify on that
point
thank you chairman um the officer just
brought up a point i was going to make
which was about the
the roach roachway development
i'm not sure was it 70 or 90 houses
but uh sorry um supported living units
there
so is that included in in this essex
county council
sorry
yeah that would be great thank you
thank you chairman um i'd like to point
out to the committee that
um the royfin
countryside estate is em
talks with having a a home
built on the one acre site adjacent to
that
development um they're in talks
with those people um i do know
so that's another big uh
if you like development for the elderly
to
to for them if they wish to to
participate in that development
thank you
members i'd like to put a motion forward
to have this um
application deferred chairman oh sorry
sorry counselor
i think it's more difficult can i carry
on with this one first
yeah i've just been advised i can
actually carry this on but i'd like this
uh
application to be preferred have i got a
second off
thank you there councillor
sorry so i'm now speaking to the
deferment presumably
um i think my question still works i'm
sorry i was struggling to hear both the
chairman's remarks and the officer's
response
if i couldn't just clarify um did the
officer state that our
current needs will be met by
the roachway development and another
development i didn't know what the other
development was
that was the same question sorry
sometimes the sound is brilliant thank
you
we shouldn't touch that so just to
clarify
um with regards to the um the housing
need
query um council strategic housing team
um have reiterated what ethics county
council said
which is that the demand is low based on
the fact that we have the roach race
site of 60 assisted living units
and five sheltered housing accommodation
units already in the watchful area
and then on top of that we also have the
application which is um under
consideration
by batches to nursing home for a 60 bed
care home
on london road rayleigh as well
oh council smith
thank you chairman um i believe that
the clarity over the existing provision
in the district is a
suitable reason for department
some interesting views that i think
perhaps need further exploring
by the report um so i i think i'm more
than happy to see
a deferment on this uh pending the
absolute clarity
of what we're going to determine and
then
next time we must come to a decision
okay
yeah this one um i propose that the
um committee um resolves to refuse the
planning
application on the grounds stated in the
officer's report
okay
is
um
members are we ready please
we're all okay item seven
this is the land north of london road
and west aurora industrial state royal
flame raley
and the officers please thank you
chairman this application is for a new
outline planning commission at the site
now known as woolsey park
the location plan on the screen shows
the land to which the application
relates edge red
and includes three separate areas the
largest of these is cited
sorry shall start again oh sorry the red
okay um so i'll i'll use the cursor but
there's so there's three
um areas of the application site and
three parcels
so the largest of which can you see my
cursor there just on the north side
so this is the largest one which runs
down here
and this covers um
or goes over part of the roar of brook
so i'll just point out the roar of brook
as well
so the roar bisects the site here
west to east so this is the largest part
of the application site
there is then another residential
another parcel
um which adjoins part of the southern
boundary so i've just edged that one
as well and then there's a smaller
parcel over
towards the eastern side okay
the wider site under the same ownership
is edged
blue um so that's the remainder that's
the
darker line you can see going around the
um the whole edge of the site
just indicated quite quickly with my
cursor there
and this wider site would continue to be
developed under the original outline
planning permission granted in 2016.
so i'll take you to the approved
parameter plan for the original outline
consent at this site
so the original outline granted in 2016
was for largely residential development
of the site up to a maximum of 500
dwellings
the beige colors on the screen so one of
those beige colored areas is indicated
by my cursor there
so these beige areas are the approved
residential development parcels
in which the 500 dwellings were to be
cited
reserve matters approval has been
granted for two of these parcels
um and development has commenced in in
both
um and some of the so development
reserve matters has been approved in
this area to the north here
and across the spine road here
this area just to the south and then
part of this area too as well
so some of the dwellings are now
actually occupied in this
for this sort of north eastern parcel
indicated by my cursor here
so i'll now take you to the proposed
parameter plan which is the subject of
the application tonight
members will note the red the redlined
areas that apologies and so they're the
same
shape as the ones i pointed out earlier
so that's this area here
and one to the southern boundary and
then this area here
towards the east and it's only
development proposed within these
redlined areas that is subject to the
current new outline application before
us this evening
this new outline application seeks an
increase in the number of dwellings at
the site up to a maximum
additional 222 dwellings compared to the
original outline planning consent for
500.
the proposed areas of the site where the
housing would be delivered are shown in
the sort of darker beige color
bit beige orange okay indicated by my
cursor here
an additional area of non-residential
use is also proposed
towards the eastern boundary so that's
in this area here it's sort of a mustard
colour
you can see with my cursor there
so members must assess the acceptability
of this new outline application against
relevant planning policy
one of the key policy considerations is
policy ser one of the site allocations
plan this policy allocated the site for
residential development
and whilst policy ser 1 references 550
dwellings
to be delivered within this site
allocation the proposed increase
is considered acceptable as it is
considered that additional dwellings
could be accommodated
and the site continue to deliver
appropriate infrastructure
indeed the council has already resolved
to approve more than the 550 dwellings
in this site allocation
as a site known as land adjacent to
grange villas if i just
i'll just scroll down a little bit so
you can see the southern area
so a site known as land adjacent grange
villas which is indicated by my cursor
here
okay just borders london road
on its southern boundary is also within
the seo one policy allocation
and has planning permission for 47
dwellings and part of the site also
known as timber grove which is
indicated by my cursor on the screen now
part of that site is also within the ser
one allocation
where a resolution to grant 83 dwellings
was taken by the council
the principle of allowing more than the
550 dwellings within the site allocation
has therefore already been accepted
policy seo one lists the infrastructure
requirements of this site allocation
and an important consideration has been
whether the proposed development
could still accommodate the necessary
on-site requirements
proportionally increased to account for
the proposed uplift indwellings
so for example in relation to play space
policy ser 1
required a minimum 0.07 hectares to be
provided to serve
550 dwellings the proposed additional up
to 222 dwellings would however require a
proportion
increase to a total of 0.12 hectares
this increased area of children's play
space would be delivered
by the provision of three separate play
areas now so on this plan
the main children's play space would
continue to be provided
in accordance with the original outline
consent in this area here so within this
kind of brightly coloured
lime green area of the site
and details of the play equipment here
have been agreed in relation to a
planning condition attached to the
original outline permission
an additional children's play space
would be delivered towards the south
eastern corner of the site so this is
indicated by my cursor
in this area here and a further informal
play space would be delivered in the
green link
that's indicated by the number three
sort of with within this
residential parcel play space would
therefore increase
to cater for the increased number of
dwellings proposed
the three place spaces that would now be
provided would be spread across the site
in the locations readily accessible to
all new residents
as well as the children's play space in
the southeastern corner so that's this
area here
allotments and youth facilities
including a kick-about area would also
be delivered in this location
again the provision of these has been
proposed to be proportionally increased
in relation to the minimum seo one
policy requirements relating to each
i'll take you to the illustrative master
plan then so this is not a plan for
determination
um but it helps give some context
the strategic open green space um to the
west which runs the length of the site
from roarth lane to the north
to london road to the south would
continue to be delivered
as approved under the original 2016
outline consent
policy seo one also required a minimum
of four hectares
of semi-natural green space to serve the
550 dwellings
as more dwellings are now proposed a
proportionate increase to 5.7 hectares
would be required
and this would be delivered within the
green space around and between so
if i just point out here there's a
swathe of green space provided
along the rorus brook so that forms part
of this 5.7 hectares
as does this area here that goes through
the north um
sort of bisecting the site east-west as
well and then you've got these
other areas around the site boundaries
in addition to this amenity green space
would continue to be provided within
residential development parcels
in particular a green link is proposed
within the residential parcel north of
the brook so that's indicated by my
cursor here
this screen link would follow on from a
similar green link provided
in the residential parcel to the north
and that's already been granted reserve
matters approval
these immunity green spaces would allow
residents ready access to the wider
areas of
strategic green space within the site if
i now go back to the
proposed parameter plan
so the site would continue to deliver
surface water drainage system which
would involve a series of attenuation
basins
the largest of which is over here to the
western boundary
with other attenuations still provided
north and south of the rothbrook
surface water captured on site would
would continue to be held within these
attenuation basins
and be discharged to the roar of brook
at rates previously accepted
i tell you this is the proposed density
plan
so the provision of more dwellings at
the site would contribute to the
maintenance of a five-year housing
supply in the district
and deliver additional affordable
housing the detailed layout of each of
the residential development parcels
would be for consideration by members
in a reserve matters application or
applications which would follow if this
new outline planning consent were
approved
it would also be at the reserve matters
stage that members would be able to
consider the scale
and design of new dwellings the plan on
screen is the submitted density plan
this shows that within the redlined
areas
so again that that's this area the
largest of which is here
the southern one and then this area to
the east
the density proposed would vary between
25 and 42 dwellings per hectare
the residential parcels towards the west
so that's these
bits here within that redlined area
would feature the lowest density housing
and on the key that's indicated to be
between
25 to 30 dwellings per hectare in this
lightest purple color
the highest density parcel would be to
the south so this is this darkest darker
color here
and that density is 38 to 42 dwellings
per hectare
the average density across the redlined
areas of the site would be some 39
dwellings per hectare
just to give members an idea reserve
matters has been approved for phase one
so that's in these areas at the top of
the site
and in this north eastern area here the
actual density of
achieved is approximately 39 dwellings
per hectare
and i can show members some images from
the development in this northeastern
area of the site to give an idea of what
this density looks like sort of in terms
of character of the built form
on the ground not perhaps the best
photos i have bought i have these
um so the photo one shows detached and
semi-detached houses facing rorith lane
and the one of the flatted blocks which
you can just see with a higher ridge
line
um poking above one of the um two-story
dwellings
and then photo two you can then see
towards the left-hand side of the screen
these three-story flatted blocks on the
north-eastern corner
adjacent to the industrial estate road
smaller residential units contained
within flattened blocks help achieve an
appropriate dwelling mix at large
strategic sites
but they do have the effect of
increasing density within a residential
parcel
and then photo three which is housing
sort of behind those sort of flats in
that same
area shows the largely detached
two-story housing within this
residential parcel
and overall in this area the average
density is 39 dwellings per hectare
it is considered that the housing that
has been built in phase one to date is
in keeping with the character of the
wider locality
of which the site is apart the proposed
average density of some 39 dwellings per
hectare that would result in the
residential development parcels subject
to the current application
would be no higher than this it is
considered that the proposed additional
up to 222 dwellings could be
achieved at an appropriate density
similar to densities within other
parcels
that already have detailed reserve
matters approval
i just take you back to the land use
plan so this is the proposed parameter
plan again on screen
instead of the on-site football pitches
proposed in the original outline
application
the applicant proposes a financial
contribution to deliver
off-site an off-site 3g football pitch
and the the current assessment of need
in the district identifies a need for
adult 3g pitches
and this proposal seeks to contribute to
meeting that need
it is envisioned that the 3g pitch will
be delivered at rayleigh leisure center
and a slight change to the wording of
the heads of term relating to this is
recommended as detailed on the
additional addendum
to require alternative new provision in
rayleigh or aurorath in the first
instance because that's closest to this
development site
if the provision of a 3g pitch could not
be secured at raley leisure center
the land set aside for a primary school
is this area here
sort of sort of dark red colour
indicated by my cursor on the screen
and that would remain unaffected by the
current new outline application proposal
as would the area for a health care
facility which is shown in the sort of
bright purple color just north of that
indicated by my cursor
a proportionate increase in the level of
financial contribution relating to both
healthcare provision and
education would be secured to respond to
the uplift in the number of dwellings
proposed
a transport assessment has been
submitted with the application and no
additional highway
related mitigation has been identified
as being required by the highway
authority
other than works to widen a section of
footway along roareth lane
and that's in this area here just east
of the site indicated by my cursive you
can see that moving on the screen
there which has become narrowed by
overgrown vegetation over time
planning condition is recommended to
deliver this and a similar additional
planning condition
as set out on the additional addendum is
recommended to achieve improvements to
parts of the pedestrian footwear
along the northern side of london road
eastward of the site
the highway works required in relation
to the original outline consent would
continue to be delivered this includes
the delivery of a bus service through
the site
a financial contribution to the new
roundabout at roth lane hambro hill
junction and highway works to london
road
clarification of the wording of the
heads of term relating to the highway
works at the downhaul road
london road junction is recommended as
detailed on the additional addendum
this change seeks to provide greater
clarity over the time
frame for works and the level of
financial contribution
in conclusion it's considered that this
site can accommodate the proposed
increased number of dwellings whilst
continuing to deliver the necessary
infrastructure
as set out in policy ser one and the
recommendation is therefore one of
approval
subjected to a section 106 legal
agreement with the heads of terms
as stated on the committee report as
revised by the addendum
and subject to the planning conditions
as detailed in the committee report
and addendum thank you
thank you so much visiting almost
cancelling newport
thank you chair this application
is seeking to add an additional 222
dwellings which i see
as an opportunity to actually deliver
220 dwellings which maximizes the profit
for the developer
and the land use however
this is nearly a 50 increase in the
original number of dwellings
that outline uh planning has been uh
given for
in the first application
the rural space
that we have when we enter rayleigh is
diminishing
and the sense of openness openness is
disappearing
although the council has accepted
uplifted
dwelling numbers at other site
allocations
on the basis that this would make best
and most efficient use
of the land it however does not
automatically address the chronic
infrastructure issues that plague
our small market town in rayleigh
it is disappointing that we hear once
again essex highways believing in the
road network will not be significantly
impacted by this development and the
additional
vehicle movements that this number of
dwellings will bring
those that live in the area already know
that the london road is heavily
congested on a daily basis
and adding a possible 400 plus vehicles
to the road network
will not only significantly impact the
london road
but also the chelmsford road
and london road and also raw rift
lane the road network is just one aspect
of this application that will have a
detrimental
impact on existing residents lives
our doctors and school places are hard
to find
with residents providing antidotal
evidence
that they have to travel to neighboring
towns in order for their children to
attend schools
that is the harsh reality of how
raley has become so over developed that
some parents now have to leave
our district for their children to
attend schools
in short this application could be
argued
is making best use of the land but it
will
increase and have a huge impact on the
quality
of life of our residents across rayleigh
and the district
i would ask members to refuse this
application
on the basis of over development which
is
unsustainable thank you
you have cancer near portman
members carol councillor weston
you chairman if this um
is um agreed this evening i can i just
speak with the officers asking the
question
because they're saying about a financial
contribution for g 3g pitchers at raley
leisure center et cetera or
other sports provision can i just have
um an agreement
a definite agreement that obviously this
is definitely going to be used and we're
not going to lose it because you are as
you are
well aware we've got um
another um sports
um center in in roche in roche which is
his whole bridge with
which is holbridge which we're looking
at 3g pitches i don't want us to be able
to lose this money because we can't use
it in the
ray leisure center so can i just have an
agreement that this this money will
definitely be used if not for rayleigh
somewhere else within our district if we
if this is approved this evening council
do a list of the questions for you and
then come back yes sir okay thank you
okay officers you're noting them down
thank you
councillor stanley
yeah thank you chairman
uh members as to from the
uh documents that we had in action
allocations plan uh february 2014
uh 3.26
page 39 the above calculations of green
space
play space and new facilities requires a
base
based on are based on 550 dwellings
being provided on the site
it is a greater number where if it a
greater number is provided
the provision of such facilities should
increase
proportionately i also like to bring
your attention
to the document
development management plan december 14
2014 in which it says
avoiding this is dm3
avoiding the loss of private immunity
space for neighbouring dwellings to
ensure adequate provision
are set out in supplementary planning
document
to housing design
on top of which i've got to read this
statement this application will give
concern to many members
especially those who have large housing
developments either recently completed
or in development
pipeline this cannot be seen as a
one-off
the developer seeks to ignore the
planning permission which was agreed by
this council in line with current
legislation
and then our district council policy the
developer wants to
wants to build a large quantity of
additional housing on land
set aside for public open space
in the approved planning permission open
spaces
makes a very significant contribution to
local quality of life
as we have seen stanley have you
actually got a question
please i had is that a statement you're
reading are you predetermined
no so is that can we have the question
that you want for the officers okay
rather than statement thank you okay
but the question is that um
as provided in our literature
of increase proportionally
to to open spaces we are increasing
the development by 222 homes
where is the increasement of open space
proportionally to those homes as we have
already as i've already stated
that the open space was agreed
for 550 homes not 772 homes
so therefore the proportionally it
should be increased
i also notice from the officer's
response
that there are play areas if you like to
call and play areas
on the outskirts and down the if you
like the center
drag or of the development which is not
quite the right place to have
play space so you're asking what your
question is whether is
the playstations the right place but
spaces rather
place spaces not playstations are they
in the right area
no not if they're in the right area but
where are they where are they
right proportionally proportionally uh
increase where are they i let the
officers
take note of that and they'll come back
to you after all members have asked
their questions
i've got another question if i can okay
thank you with the increase
in the development this will also
increase the prolonged
water discharge from the site
to downstream lower downstream
and there is no provision as such at the
moment
to say where that water is going to be
kept
other than in the ponds that are already
there for 550 homes
so again i ask where is it
proportionally increased
the water retention retention to the
site
where is that going to be held because
the downstream as you very well know it
floods ever so
quickly and it will flood longer periods
thank you
thank you i noticed that council stanley
has actually got a copy of the
2000 february 2014 document
on this table it's a
document that took this council
a very very long time to produce
it factored in all the
relevant nuances of development
in the district at that time
but i don't believe it's fully
considered to be out of date
and the site that we're talking about is
the implementation of what one of the
areas
allocated for housing within that
document
and at the time of the the existing
application um it it was felt that it
was appropriate
so things have changed and cancer
stanley was talking about
the the open space i believe it was
about four hectares of
of natural semi-natural green space or
or
greater than that was required
um there was more space than that on the
development
but it clearly said to my understanding
that if the number of houses
on the site were to increase
then proportionately the amount of green
space
would also need to increase um
just by its nature the blocks of housing
that are now
uh seeking approval will will decrease
that
so i'm i'm not at all convinced
um by the intensification
of of the site i think also
we've got an increase in a clear
increase
in the amount of housing
this housing is not required
to provide
additional numbers to our our housing
need
we had in the last application that we
considered
a short while ago the statement of 6.3
years supply of housing need
been provided at this moment in time so
we haven't we haven't got the
requirement for this site to contribute
we haven't got a shortfall in other
areas
uh in the district and this site's not
required
to maintain that five-year supply
so i i'm thinking
that with the basis of our opinion
it was taken when the
main substantive applications in place
was taken
plus one or two small adjustments that
we have accepted
i don't believe that substantially the
the factors around that have have
changed i can accept that
there will be um adjustments to section
106 agreements
and so on but on page
7.50
4.33 it specifically comes to
education and
i don't i don't i i've tried to
understand it but i still don't quite
get
how there'd be a 10 000 pound reduction
in part of the education contribution
as a result of of 10 uh as a result of
potentially 220 more houses
and also on the final paragraph
final bullet point um i
i accept the essex county council
point about the closure period uh
not be it being brought forward i think
that
from a place an education place planning
point of view
to come to a decision before people have
even
moved in before families have even got
established
and uh and started their families to
come to decisions
about whether the education site is is
needed or not is just not appropriate
and just one what one of the small aside
on 7.51 4.37
it mentions specifically about charging
points
and i think all members should note that
clearly in that paragraph we have now
got stated
that charging points are apart are part
and parcel
of new development it's here in the
report now
so from this point on if if we see
news how new housing development we can
properly access
have the anticipation that charging
points will be provided
but that's going off a point so
i'm i'm not convinced
by the need
that is attempted to be demonstrated
within this this report at this moment
in time
thank you
thank you chairman i was going to raise
points raised by councillor stanley and
councillor smith but they've done it
much better than i would have done so
i'll leave that there just apart from
say that i agree with what they say
um i wanna i'd like just to come back to
the
3g pitch if i know this has been raised
by council mrs weston
um and obviously just for the record i
represent holbridge as a ward
as well um i
the the 3g pitch is off of this
site um it's not a long way away
but if a 3g pitch in holbridge would in
no way serve this site
i'm not sure anywhere in within the
district would serve the site very well
where i'm aware space would be available
and i feel that we're taking this 3g
pitch would have been junior pitches and
something else on the site itself
so this is open space moved away from
the site and it will take up open space
at the leisure center maybe or or
somewhere else
um which i i really don't agree with
which goes back to uh councillor smith's
point
on on the open space again um
in addition if it is at the rady leisure
center
it might be a 3g pitch but is it
available for the use of the people on
that site
is there going to be a charge how would
it be managed i've i've got real
concerns about this i think if it's a 3g
pitch it should be available for all to
use it should
there shouldn't be a financial penalty
for residents of this site to use it
in particular it's off it's theirs
they're paying for it
in one one way or another um
i'll leave that there for members to
mull over and for
an answer from the officers if i may um
the only other point
councillor newport mentioned about
doctors i understand
this application has suggested that
there are maybe doctors places available
in houlbridge for
residents on this site well it's quite
interesting because the holby
application suggested that residents
might want to
use the doctors in downhill road to
fulfill their overflow so i'm not not
sure how much we are connected with
these
that's it thank you thank you council
councillors
notwithstanding the points that have
been made by
members previously
in the addendum writer to item 7 that
was actually
sent out to us today
the head of terms 13
where we're talking about the highways
works being done within five years of
the date is the decision
this seems to um be in contradiction to
what was actually approved
for the holbridge site where it was
actually based
on the amount of houses that were in
occupancy which
does seem to make much more sense than
to actually
putting it into a date from the decision
where that could be um quite
detrimental on the amount of extra
traffic that could be
within those five years i would suggest
that it would be a better wording within
heads of term 13 not to put that as uh
for the highway works be done within
five years but to it
for it to be done within a term of a
certain amount of
houses occupied for which i'd need to
actually
refer defer to the officers to recommend
what that would be as uh in my mind
a much more sensible view to the
timing of any necessary upgrades in the
road
just turn that on um so i'll take them
in order
um councillor west and you had a
question about the contribution towards
the 3g pitch
so on the addendum
it's set out on the additional addendum
which was circulated this evening
so 0.3 so ahead of term three so
that contribution will be paid to
rochford council for the delivery
in the first instance of a new senior 3g
pitch at raley leisure center
however if um because planning
permission would need to be granted for
that
if for any reason and we don't envisage
an issue at the moment but if there were
an issue to arise
that money would not go back to the
developer immediately
it would be for the council to then
consider
other provision um related to sport
infrastructure
in rayleigh and roarth in the first
instance because those
areas closest to the site but then there
is also the in
ability for this head of term for the
council to consider that
even even wider area so we can take the
whole district into account then
and so the idea of putting these
other possibilities in is to ensure that
that that money is spent so you do get
some infrastructure provision
with those funds hopefully that
clarifies that one
um
so the question about the proportionate
increase in
open space from councillor stanley
i've got next on my list so i think what
we need to be careful
to do is to assess this current new
outline application
not against the original
approved outline application so it's not
a comparison of this application versus
what was approved
it must be an assessment of the current
application
against policy so the ser one
policy requirements set out the minimum
amounts of open space provision that are
required
of a site for five of the site
allocation which is
550 set out in the site allocation plan
the original application was for 500
and that original application proposed
if you like vastly more
than the minimum amounts of open space
that
the policy required but this application
would still achieve
a proportional increase on the policy
minimum requirements
so this application would not obviously
have a proportionate increase on the
original
outline consent but that's not the
assessment to be made that we need to
assess this application in relation to
the policy minimum requirements
so specifically they are four hectares
of semi-natural green space and this
application
would still deliver 5.7 so that
is proportionately increased even though
the residential parcels are increasing i
hope that's clear
if you need me to clarify that again i
can try
but it might not appear that the open
space is being proportionately increased
because
if you compare it to the original
outline consent but that's not what we
need to do
i think we need to you know assess this
proposal
against the council's ser one policy
requirements
okay the play spaces
so again those would be proportionately
increased compared to those
minimums set out in ser one
the policy requirements and there would
be one here
so there's one here provided one here
and then an additional one here so
in the original outline there were two
play spaces required we've now
got three provided
um in terms of the surface water
drainage strategy
what the applicant is required to do at
this outline stage
is provide the sort of in principle
what's going to happen to the water on
the site
and the detailed drainage strategy would
be
then required to be submitted in
relation to the planning condition
that's set out
and is required by the lead local flood
authority
so at the if outline permission were
granted
development could not commence in any of
these residential parcels within the red
lines
until detailed drainage
plans of the attenuation basins
appropriately sized
to take account of the increase in
impermeable surface as a result of the
increased development parcels
had been approved by the lead local
flood authority
those that is for the detail rather than
to be
provided at the outline stage but
ultimately the drainage strategy is much
as
was proposed previously and agreed so
these attenuation basins
will hold water surface water and then
it will
discharge to the rothbrook at the lower
one in one year greenfield rates
which is actually an improvement on the
original stipulation
so in the original outline two of these
ponds were agreed to drain
at a a higher rate so the one in ten
year rate
and it's all set that's set out in the
committee report
but the the ponds now would be
draining the rate of discharge at this
one in one year rate
and the lead local flood authority have
considered the issue of the volumes of
water
because i know cancer sunny was
concerned about the volumes of water not
just the rate of water leaving the site
and the idea is to limit to the lower
discharge rate for all storm events
so even in the high intensity storm
events water leaving those
ponds is restricted to that
lowest one in one year greenfield runoff
rate
and in storm events i'm told by the llfa
the lead local flood authority that that
helps situations because
the the water is sort of um the rate
over time so over time um the rate is
kind of reduced so they are satisfied
that they have looked at the drainage
strategy that's been provided at this
outline stage and they're content that
with the conditions imposed
the scheme would be acceptable and would
not increase
flood risk by as a result of surface
water elsewhere
downstream um
in terms of the education contributions
um
there was a reference looking back at
the um committee report to a ten
thousand pound reduction
there was a 10 000 pound reduction
reference in the original 106 and what
the
educational authority want is
essentially that deleted so
it's not them paying less if you like
it's um
that that reduction that they could have
benefited from that provision
is will be removed and the edges
education site option period
um that's been requested to be extended
would that extension would also be
incorporated into the section one six
by the officer that uh
the if you like the open spaces
and if you put little parcels together
you'll get a
bigger open space it's very true but
there's no more
open space it's gone it's gone to
development
but if you put the little parcels you
can have a bigger open space
but so the question is it still hasn't
resolved the the uh
if you like proportionally to open space
and as for the water discharge yes
the water discharge will be the same but
downstream
it will be longer and if you're in a
flood zone which you are downstream
that flood zone becomes not one hour but
four hours
or five hours we don't know but it's a
longer term
so the people down there and you're
discharging water
at the same rate but unfortunately
you're gonna have to be
it doesn't answer it doesn't answer the
question
where the water is going to be kept
because there are no other ponds
and also it doesn't and the suds as far
as i'm aware
they understand that the duration of
flood
downstream will be longer and therefore
they must look at this as a priority
to reducing the longer term of the
longer
span of time in flood plain
she can't clarify i've already spoken to
the officer today
and she she can't clarify
any further than what the suds can
clarify
when and if this development is approved
i propose if i may that this
application be refused on the grounds of
over development no
propulsionally increase in open space
and the retention of water on-site for
these
extra 222 homes have your secondary
we now discuss the
motion to refuse
would look officers like to comment
first on the reasons
yes thank you chair um
i think i might need to go over this
proportionate increase in open space
again
because i think any reason for refusal
around that i think
is potentially quite problematic so i
think
what i'm asking what we the assessment
that needs to be made
is setting aside trying to forget
the original outline application
and looking at this application as a new
application
the first application if you like on the
site does this application
deliver a proportional increase in open
space
compared to what policy ser one requires
and it does
so i really would guard against any
reason for refusal around
the lack of demonstrable
proportionate increase in open space
above the policy requirement
i think in relation to over development
uh
simply stating that the application is
over development
would not be enough at appeal
we need to be very clear about what the
harm
caused is
um and i i can't give give any more i i
you know in relation to that um
and the water on the site um i think
um i have spoken to the llfa today to to
clarify things
um their response remains the same and
is clear they have considered the
information submitted in relation to the
surface water drainage scheme
and they are content there's no
objection
subject to the imposition of a condition
which is
wordy you know it requires a lot of the
developer at
the detailed stage to make sure that the
ponds are adequately sized to deal with
surface water from this site and to
ensure
that the rate of discharge is
appropriately controlled
and those rates of discharge would be no
greater than what has been
agreed already so we we would not have
the support of the lead local flood
authority in relation to
a can a reason for refusal around
concern about surface water drainage
having an adverse impact
off site
thank you chairman um i'm just going to
still say state my support for the the
motion
i would like the officers to state how
much open space was
in the original application and how much
open space is in this application
i am getting quite fed up of being told
by
officers that if we agree an application
and it comes back to us
we can't change anything that we've
agreed before this was essentially
passed
a number of years ago with the amount of
open space in the
original application with 550 dwellings
i cannot support an application which
comes back with another i think it's 44
more dwellings on the site and less open
space than the original application
um i understand what the officers are
saying that that they feel it should be
judged on what was in the policy not in
what we passed but however it was the
other way around we are told that we
have to
do it based on what was a past or
refused
previously and that's what i'm going on
now
um so i'd like the answer on the open
space how much was agreed
in the original application how much
he's been agreed in this because it must
be less how can they be building
more dwellings and have more open space
it isn't possible
and the usability of that the open space
that is here
is questionable they are quite small
pockets
and the officer indicated the the
northern boundary along rorth lane has
been part of this
open space um it's a
bund as far as i can tell at the moment
i believe it's going to remain abundant
i don't think it's a usable open space
in that sense
yes it's open space there's nothing on
it there's no
buildings on it but it's not usable for
for residents
it's a it's a band it's a a hillock to
protect the
the the the development from the
the road noise that i just drew um so so
i do question whether this is
usable open space in in the sense that
we think it should be
within this application and i i will
leave that there
oh yes i can yes um
oh it's on um
i i don't have a figure
for the amount of open space that was
provided on the original application
versus
what's proposed here but i would just
reiterate that if this
were to go to appeal refused in on a
ground relating to this
an inspector would assess the current
application
in relation to policy ser one not the
current application
in relation to the the another or the
original outline application
but yes clearly there is less open space
proposed now because the residential
parcels are increasing
and there's some non-residential
development as well
but the assessment i sort of reiterate
but i think it must be made in relation
to your policy requirements
and the minimum amounts of space as set
out in those
and does this achieve that proportionate
increase in relation to those
the only other thing i might mention is
that in the mppf it does talk about sort
of open space and it does
allow for um open space to have a visual
aspect as well as
um a sort of you know can i walk on that
land so
so water bodies or bodies what can be
part of open space and function as that
and it would still
be considered as part of that quotient
you know that area of space
because it has a visual aspect to it
from people being able to see across it
and enjoy the space in that regard too
thank you right members i think we've
had a good uh discussion and answer
and answers from our officers um can we
have a vote
oh sorry i've just been advised you can
you restate
the reasons for refusals to make it
clear council's family yes
over development lack of open
space or provision off
for the extra dwellings
and um
can i say
there are no plans for
attenuation of surface water
thank you councillor do you agree with
those
you said will you second that yes thank
you right members
can i have a take a vote on
the recommendation for refusal please
can you keep your hands up
and until sonia indicates otherwise
thank you
thank you members for exception
sorry those against the reasons for
refusal
those members thank you members those
members that are staying abstain
you have one
that's lost thank you
right now we go back to the original
recommendation
[Music]
that the it is proposed that the
committee resolves and approves this
application
all right i will move this from the
chance to have this approved can i have
a second to please
oh daniel thank you council lefty
members can i have a vote on this place
for approval
in favor
oops
any obsessions
that's passed thank you members
item 8 for referred items from a
referred weekly list there is none
so i will close this meeting
sorry 21 38 thank you members for
attending